لقد رأينا عشرات الآلاف من
المتظاهرين نزلوا إلى الشوارع هذا
الأسبوع احتجاجًا على الظلم العنصري
ووحشية الشرطة. ما هو
رد فعلك الشخصي على هذه اللحظة ، هل
تعتقد أن البلد ليس
نقطة تحول ، فنحن نلجأ إلى نقاط التحول.
يعني أن الحزب الجمهوري الذي
اعتقد الرئيس أنهم محصنون نوعًا
ما يمكنهم الذهاب ليقولوا أي شيء يريدونه
وحتى أكثر إثارة للقلق من أن الكونجرس
سيجلس هناك ولن يقاوم بأي شكل من الأشكال
ما يفعله الرئيس والكلمة الوحيدة التي
يجب أن أستخدمها فيما يتعلق به.
لكنه كان يفعل على مدى السنوات العديدة
الماضية ، إنها كلمة لم أكن
لأستخدمها من قبل لم أكن لأستخدمها أبدًا مع
أي من الرؤساء الأربعة الذين
عملت معهم لأنه يكذب أنه يكذب بشأن الأشياء
ويبتعد عنها لأن الناس لم يفعلوا ذلك.
نحمله المسؤولية ، وأثناء
مشاهدته ، نحتاج إلى مشاهدتها
من الكونغرس ، أشاهد أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ وهم يتجهون
إلى الغرفة في اليوم الآخر بعد كل
هذا الانهيار الجيد ، يقول التقرير
إنه  هل عليك أن تقول ما لديك
لتقوله ليس لديهم ما يقولونه إنهم
لن يتفاعلوا ، ولذا فنحن لسنا
دولة رئيس فقط لدينا
كونغرس لدينا محكمة عليا ولكن
الأهم من ذلك كله أن لدينا الناس  من
الولايات المتحدة ، الذين صوتوا
لمن صوتوا له والذين صوتوا
لصالحه
، لم أتمكن من التصويت له في 96 ،
وبالتأكيد لا يمكنني بأي حال من الأحوال دعم
الرئيس ترامب هذا العام